hallo herzlich willkommen meine torten
welt heute gibt es eines meiner
lieblings rezepte ich mache mich halt
schokokuchen und dieser schokokuchen ist
sehr weich und zart und wenn ihr wissen
wollt wie ihr ihn machen können bleibt
jetzt tragen zuerst braucht ihr 125
milliliter wasser einen esslöffel
schwand oder joghurt oder creme fraiche
120 gramm butter 150 gramm zucker einen
esslöffel vanillezucker oder eine
packung vanillezucker 10 kam cacau und
100 gramm zucker schokolade und später
braucht ihr dann noch ein einen
teelöffel backpulver und 125 gramm mehl
nehmt euch jetzt diese ersten so taten
und gibt sie alle nacheinander in einem
kleinen topf da kommt jetzt also die
schokolade kakao vanille zucker zucker
die butter das wasser und der joghurt
oder die creme fraiche oder der
esslöffel schmandt stellt dann den hut
auf kleine flamme und lasst alles
schmelzen aber nicht kochen
wenn es dann alles vollständig aufgelöst
hat nehmen sie das gemisch vom herd und
lass es etwa 20 minuten abkühlen
wenn das es soweit ausgekühlt ist kommen
die restlichen drei zutaten dazu dazu
gebt ihr zuerst das backpulver mit zu
mehr und verrührt es ganz kurz
dann schlagt ihr noch das ei auf das
mache ich grundsätzlich immer in einer
extra schüssel man weiß nämlich nie open
ein ich mal schlecht ist dann müsst ihr
nicht das ganze den ganzen tag
wegschmeißen
jetzt kommt es einfach hier mit rein und
wird verrührt und dann kommt darauf das
mehl mit dazu und das war's dann auch
schon das ist dann schon fertig ich habe
sie eine 18 cm springform die habe ich
am boden mit backpapier ausgelegte ihr
braucht den rand nicht ein so wetten
dass wird später nicht angeben
da kommt jetzt der teig rein
ihr könnt auch für die menge gut mit 20
cm springform nehmen den rest noch aus
kraft der kuchen wird jetzt in der 18
da springform bei 170 grad etwa 40
minuten gebacken
in einer 20 zentimeter springform backte
etwa 30 minuten mit neuer kuchen fertig
ist sie dann etwas so aus dann gehe ich
da einmal kurz mit einem messer am rand
entlang öffnet die springform und dann
könnt ihr euren kuchen anheben
auf eine tortenplatte setzen müsste echt
aufpassen der es so rasch und so zart
dass er schnell kaputt gehen kann und
wenn ihr jetzt wollt könnt ihr den noch
mit puderzucker bestäuben oder eine
schulklasse drüber machen aber der ist
eigentlich so schon schokoladig genug
ich hoffe das rezept gefällt euch in der
show kuchen schmeckt euch genauso gut
wie mir und dann wünsche ich euch viel
spaß beim nachbacken und bis zum
nächsten mal